so rudy giuliani is not the only
whacked-out lawyer
representing donald trump in his futile
attempts to overturn the results of the
2020 election
which joe biden won there's this other
lawyer named
sydney powell now last week when i noted
sydney powell seems absolutely out of
her mind
during that bizarre press conference at
which rudy giuliani's face
melted some people wrote to me and said
david you know it's
kind of sounds like you're making fun of
sydney powell's accent
i guess she's southern that's not what
it was
with any accent the things sydney powell
was saying make no sense she suggested
last week
that there was a conspiracy to steal the
election from donald trump by joe biden
involving this is not a joke venezuela
and cuba
the long dead hugo chavez and nicholas
maduro
george soros antifa some guy named eric
coomer and the clinton foundation she
seemed
completely out of her mind we now have
more video evidence that she is indeed
very sick she was interviewed on newsmax
tv over the weekend newsmax is this
even crazier alternative to fox news
that donald trump has been recommending
along with oan
and she claimed that they will be making
a
biblical filing about voter fraud
against donald trump she says the
the filings are coming and they will be
biblical
what does that mean i have no idea see
if you can figure it out
you know i know you say you want to do
arguing in court you are an attorney
you're not a press secretary but you all
did have a press conference
last week jordan sekulow said that
there's going to be a filing soon in
georgia
that would be explosive can you tell us
anything can you make some news with us
here tonight
tell us anything new that you're going
to present in that filing in georgia
well i'm i
i can't say that yet but hopefully this
week
we will we will get it ready to file
sydney what's in it it will it will be
biblical
biblical guys we we have to be allowed
to call this what it is
these are delusions this is mental
illness we can't say
well because she's a christian this is
not mental illness a
biblical filing about fraud in a court
of
law guys please this is where you know
if this
were not trump's lawyer and this
were not a christian if they said
something equivalent to this you would
be looking at a 72-hour
cycle for an individual like this she
also said that there are likely
thousands of people
involved in the conspiracy i mean how
big of a
you know if if this happened how big of
a conspiracy how many people would have
had to have been in on something like
this
oh gosh uh probably thousands including
the people running the machines at each
of the polls
polling centers we know for example that
one of the higher higher-ups of dominion
went to detroit the night of the
election to
to handle things himself and we
also have evidence that there were any
number of
vpn lines open to the internet for
foreign actors to be meddling in it yeah
thousands of people in on it one of the
things we know from experience
is that when there are more than a
handful of people involved
you can't cover it up and yet we had the
texas governor
offering a million dollars as a reward
for proof of voter fraud nobody's been
able to collect the million dollars
their sworn affidavits keep getting
dismissed in court
courts keep finding there's no merit to
any of these claims if
thousands of people are involved there
would be widespread
undeniable proof you can't cover it up
if thousands of people are involved
and then sydney powell goes back into
the stuff about venezuela venezuelan
witnesses has anybody given you an
explanation
that that as to why they had to turn the
machines off
you talk about how the machines got
turned off
our key our witness from venezuela who
saw it all created and how it worked
said that he knew as soon as the
machines were turned off in those key
states it was because we the people
in voting uh trump and voting for trump
in a landslide election had essentially
broken the algorithm that had been
pre-programmed into the machine
so they had to stop counting in those
states did you hear that one
people voted for trump so overwhelmingly
that it broke the machine algorithms
whatever that means she says trump lost
by
6 million and she's saying trump won by
so much
that it broke the machines this
is a very sick person and sadly people
fall for
it and it has even become too much for
the trump campaign they put out a
statement yesterday after this interview
came out
saying that sydney powell is practicing
law on her own
she's not part of donald trump's legal
team she's not a trump lawyer
she's essentially been fired because up
until yesterday
she did appear to be all of those things
donald trump even previously tweeted
about her
that he has the best lawyers and
representatives including sydney powell
which we have up on the screen for you
it's just a hilarious comedy of errors
the trump campaign now distancing from
this lunatic woman as quickly as they
can
but people fall for it i got a very
distressing email over the weekend from
a viewer
who said david my mom completely fell
for that press conference
the press conference you and i likely
watched and we see rudy giuliani's hair
dye melting
and sidney powell blaming antifa and
george soros and
and venezuela for stealing the election
and we recognize these are ill people
this viewer's mom fell for it and
thought that sidney powell is just a
brilliant lawyer
doing god's work and this viewer spent
hours
convincing his mom that that's not the
case
it's really scary stuff and as with
trumpism in general
the really scary part is the number of
people
just falling for this nonsense hook line
and sinker
biblical submissions proving
voter fraud against donald trump sad
and scary we'll have more about this on
our instagram page
we are at david pakman show on instagram
while you're there you can follow me on
instagram as well
at david.pacman if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire
book on your way home from work they
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video